rue does not have it figured out
who does not know what she's doing
hollywood isn't so glamorous when you're
shooting a dark and intense show like
euphoria zendaya has dealt with
emotional trauma lasting scars total
exhaustion and intense anxiety we're
taking a look at just how far this
actress went for the role of a lifetime
number one from disney to euphoria the
zendaya story it's a big jump it's very
different everyone was surprised when
the disney star made the leap from her
sweet and wholesome days on the disney
channel to hbo in the incredibly mature
and dramatic euphoria there were no
steps in between that's why people think
it's such a stretch for me to play this
character there's a lot of people who
probably think i can't do it because
they don't truly understand my
personality and i get it i'm a disney
kid there's a lot to prove
well we think the emmy can speak for
itself she definitely proves something
number two going to those deep dark
places has a cost it was a long
a long eight months yes she was working
on a major show but the stress of how
the show was being received and living
up to expectations could really get to
her it gave me a lot of anxiety every
week but something i deal with i have
anxiety luckily a stellar support system
has allowed her to continue to work
while taking care of her mental health
number three when zendaya is in she's in
preparing to do this show and exist in
the world of euphoria day after day
requires a ton of emotional stamina it's
very hard i kind of we're kind of still
stuck in it i think and it's not just
the baggage of the weight of the show
but it's also we truly enjoyed each
other's company their biggest support
system on those sets really is each
other though on screen their
relationships are pretty fraught behind
the scenes we all love each other and we
care about each other because we've had
to be so vulnerable in front of each
other during this show so if anything uh
we miss each other like it's this weird
thing you know of like oh it's finally
over but it's like oh but i want to go
back you know number four she's
unpredictable that's for sure when roo
was around anything could happen she
could hit someone she could hurt someone
she could yell at someone or she could
just be quiet and you don't know when
it's gonna happen all those combative
and often spontaneous feelings made
going through the motions each day a
real struggle especially because of how
deeply zendaya loves rue as an actress
it's painful because i care about her
and i don't want to ruin her life i
don't want her to say these things
number five what is a healthy schedule
supposed to look like probably not this
zendaya had some wacky hours i've been
nocturnal meaning i slept for two hours
last night because i'm still on night
shoot schedule and can't get rid of it
day shoot night shoot 12 hour days it
all took a toll but hey that exhaustion
could do her some favors when she was
shooting no matter how she felt though
there was really just one place that she
wanted to be i want to go back to
euphoria that's where i live i want to
go back number six we thought the first
season was intense we didn't know what
was coming it's a very different season
to be honest within the show and their
performances the actors push themselves
to their absolute limits pulling out
performances that are surprising and
moving it's brutal the first season
brought us into their world and while
for the most part the characters and
structure are the same tonally it's
different i think it's far more
emotional than the first season we
fortunately get bits of comedy sprinkled
in but for every laugh we get a
heartbreak too the highs are high the
lows are low and as the series goes on
well everyone's hearts were breaking to
portray her going through it hurt me
it's just a really painful cycle to
watch her go through and i didn't
particularly enjoy having to watch her
deal with that number seven that r
rating ain't for nothing this is not an
easy show yeah that's for sure anyone
who's seen the series knows this content
is brutal and doesn't shy away from any
subject the most important thing was to
not shy away from how ugly those moments
can be and while the actress knows her
role is just a job my brain can say okay
i'm pretending but when i'm doing it my
body and my heart don't know that it's
not real it can be exhausting in that
way and it can make you feel bad because
she does things that i don't want her to
do and say but here i am the process
required her full commitment but luckily
roo's story was in good hands it's gonna
take a lot but i think you know rue
deserves um that care number eight the
whole euphoria team is a family and
every single one of them was key in
getting the show made we're really truly
uh well in that together getting to feel
safe with co-stars while filming this
content was an absolute dream i felt
like i said extremely supportive as i
was screaming and yelling in the car and
losing my mind i had two beautiful
actresses um nika and storm who had my
back everyone's patience was evident
especially the crew without whom none of
this action would be captured in the
first place
i feel really lucky to have the crew
that we have of really dedicated and
talented individuals who literally
dedicate their whole life they might not
be pouring their deepest emotions out
for the world to see but being in the
midst of all that chaos is intense
i may be up there screaming and yelling
but they're right there with me number
nine they work together they cry
together seriously sometimes there's a
full-on collective cry sesh on set i
think what's special about euphoria is
that it's the kind of set where if i cry
often there's 12 people behind the
camera crying with me so i don't feel
like i'm by myself and i feel like they
have my back we tear up just watching
the show being right in the middle of
the action that's a different story our
literal crew will cry with me it's great
but it's because i feel that and they're
going through it with me now that's a
serious bonding experience number 10
potentially the most exhausting scene in
the series the fact that she filmed
right after shooting for dune in a
hundred degree weather made it that much
harder it was so intense and scary to
tackle and obviously something that
would be incredibly emotionally taxing
but also physically taxing zendaya
performed a ton of the stunts herself it
was a very tough day i mean i beat
myself up i still have some scars on my
legs and got quite a few bruises while
her body hurt it was the emotional
struggle that really got her down i'd
fall into a bed of fake cactuses a
million times and it wouldn't be as
painful as having to yell in someone you
care about space things you don't mean
and words that don't belong to you those
may have been the most emotional moments
but filming in the streets it was very
scary because they were all stunt
drivers but they had to drive toward me
and stop as i'm running through the
middle of the street number eleven
normally an actor learns lines works on
their character but it wasn't so easy
for euphoria zendaya did her due
diligence and prepped but it didn't
necessarily serve her roo is complicated
and all of the characters are for some
things like that you can't prepare i get
in my head if i overthink things too
much and then i'll block myself when it
came to the most excruciating moments
like the intervention she did what she
had to do to take care of herself i
tried to distance myself from it as much
as i could so that i wouldn't psych
myself out i do that i get in my head
and then i can't just let go and you
really can't have any fears when you do
a scene like that we think we can all
agree that zendaya is fearless number 12
they didn't choose to have a break but
the whole team had a massive one between
seasons and uh well it didn't go over so
well at first literally since the day we
wrapped i was ready to start season two
being forced to shut down production
turned out to be a blessing in disguise
in the end i think gave us this
beautiful time to kind of like not be so
in our heads and be a little bit more
outside of euphoria to kind of properly
get inside of what it really means
without the pressure of success in
meeting expectations in their way the
team could bring more intense tv magic
number 13. she's definitely not just a
disney star now going on such an
intimate and intense journey with this
character has brought out different
parts of the actress before playing rue
i didn't understand in grave detail the
experience of what it means to be an
addict nor did i feel i had enough maybe
some but not enough empathy for that
experience now she feels it's made her
more empathetic and emotional towards
others that's a pretty special takeaway
zendaya earned her emmy and honestly so
did this entire team it really does take
a village
which part of filming do you think would
have been most painful